so this video is about post gallbladder
surgery now whether you had your
gallbladder already removed or you're
contemplating getting gallbladder
surgery
this video is very very important for
you because any time you're going to get
rid of a very important organ it's
essential that you understand the
purpose of that organ and what's inside
that organ
what is the gallbladder and what is this
function well the gallbladder is mainly
a sac that
holds bile salts which i'm going to get
to in a second it stores bile until the
next time you eat
and very importantly it concentrates
bile to a factor of 5x
so the significance of that is that when
you eat the gallbladder contracts and
releases a very concentrated form of
bile salts and once you have your
gallbladder removed
you don't have that concentration of
bile salts you have a trickling of bile
salts down
from these little bile ducts into the
small intestine and so gallbladder
surgery is all about removing the
symptoms of a gallbladder whether it's a
stone or other reason but is this all
about symptoms what about the function
of bile itself and what it does
i'm going to explain that so bile is
created from your liver and it trickles
down through these little tubes into the
gallbladder and then it also goes down
into the small intestine so bile is a
detergent that breaks up
fat okay so in this little jar i have
fat okay
and then with this
i have detergent
dishwashing liquid so bile is detergent
so let's see what happens
mix it
with a fat
so i'm going to just
take some purified bowel salts
and put it in this oil here
okay
now we're going to
mix it up
now notice what happens
it emulsifies or breaks up the fat into
smaller particles
okay that's what bile does
it's a detergent that breaks down fat
into smaller particles
so
the enzyme called lipase in your
pancreas
can
easily break it down into even smaller
particles for the small intestine to
absorb the things in fat
like
fat soluble vitamins so bile is
essential for extracting the fat soluble
vitamins
from your food like vitamin a if you're
deficient about m a you can't see in the
dark vitamin e
it's for the heart so a lot of vitamin e
is stored in the muscles it's stored in
pituitary to help with maintaining sex
hormones so vitamin e is a very very
essential vitamin and also for
protecting the heart it prevents
inflammation and oxidation from the
inside of your arteries so if you don't
have enough bile and you can't extract
this vitamin e the heart suffers the
hormones suffer then we have vitamin d
which is
probably one of the most important
vitamins and the majority of the
population is deficient in vitamin d so
without bile you can't absorb vitamin d
then we have vitamin k both k1 and k2 if
you're deficient in vitamin k1 you bleed
easily and you have bruising if you're
deficient in vitamin k2 you have calcium
that builds up in the wrong places in
the arteries and in your joints now bile
is also necessary for extracting
essential fatty acids as in omega-3
fatty acids which are very very
important as an anti-inflammatory for
heart health and there's a huge long
list of many other things as well now
when we get to gallstones what is a
gallstone a gallstone is a super
concentrated
cholesterol stone so if we have too much
cholesterol
and not enough
bile salts we get stones there's either
not enough production of bile from the
liver because there's some problem in
the liver or there's a problem in the
tubes the bile ducts or there's a
problem in the gallbladder but having a
bile
will prevent gall stones
people think it's the fat that causes
gallstones no it's not it's the lack of
bile in fact it's your cholesterol that
makes
bile and without cholesterol you can't
even make bile another function of bile
is in helping the conversion
from t4 to t3 it helps the thyroid
convert hormones into the active form of
the thyroid hormone so if there's a
problem with the liver or the bile
you're not going to be able to convert
these hormones as well and you could end
up with a
hypothyroid problem all right another
function of bile number five is the
support of blood sugars so it does help
in the regulation of blood sugars if you
don't have enough bile it can adversely
affect your blood sugars all right
number six and this is an interesting
one
when you eat food there are certain fats
that you eat that have beneficial things
essential fatty acids and fat soluble
vitamins
but
is there any type of fat soluble
nutrients in
vegetables and the answer is yes
certain phytonutrients
like carotenoids
chlorophyll
is fat soluble
so in order to
absorb
those really important phytonutrients
that give you additional health benefits
you need
bile this is one good reason to add the
olive oil to your salad or to eat
vegetables with some type of fat whether
it's butter or coconut oil
or olive oil it helps in the absorption
of these fat soluble vitamins but you
also need bile salts so i hope you're
beginning to see some of the
important factors of having enough bile
in your body and having a gallbladder as
well all right number seven
bile helps you get rid of excessive
cholesterol in fact having the bile
salts accounts for the majority of
cholesterol breakdown so not having
enough bile salts
especially when you go through the
ketogenic diet because you're going to
be consuming more fat
could account for a spike in cholesterol
especially since you are on a low carb
diet and you're tapping into the fat
cell which also has not just
triglycerides but it also has
cholesterol and that cholesterol has to
be extracted from the fat and it has to
go through the liver and out through the
bile ducts with the help of your bile
next point is that
bile helps you release toxins without a
bile you become more toxic you can't get
rid of toxins all right number nine bile
is like an anti-pathogenic
factor
it helps to kill off
microbes
especially in the small intestine so
most of the friendly bacteria
are in the large intestine not the small
intestine we don't want a lot of
microbes in the small intestine because
microbes even friendly microbes compete
for nutrients
ninety percent of all the
absorption of nutrients happens in the
small intestine so we don't want this
competition
we want most of the microbes to stay
down a large bowel if you don't have
enough bile these microbes tend to exist
more in the small intestine and that
condition is called small intestinal
bacterial
overgrowth
sibo and one of the causes for that is a
lack of bile and one of the remedies is
to take more bile cells to help kill off
these microbes and this is why biola is
so important in the body in fact a great
majority of your bile is recycled
because your body considers it viable in
fact the microbes in your body the
friendly microbes actually make bile
salts they make a secondary bile salts
and one of the reasons for that is it's
a strategic anti-pathogenic
strategy it tends to
kill off the bad bacteria but the good
bacteria
are not bothered by it except if there's
excessive good bacteria in the wrong
place and number 10
bile is alkaline so when it's released
into the small intestine just beneath
the stomach
you have this acid coming through the
stomach that gets neutralized by bile
salts so both
bile
and the juices from the pancreas coming
out called bicarbonates are alkaline to
help neutralize the acid if you don't
have that
alkaline material the acid could burn a
hole in your small intestine and create
an ulcer and other issues so we need it
to help alter the ph at the level of the
small intestine so bile is crucial in so
many different aspects
but especially in regulating cholesterol
because if we don't have enough bile the
cholesterol can develop these little
stones called gallstones as well as
gallbladder sludge okay which are
micro crystals of stone and that can
block the bile ducts and create some of
the same symptoms that a gallstone would
and so when you get your gallbladder
checked and there's no stones present
you may have a either a stone in the
ducts the bile ducts or sludge which is
very difficult to show up even on a cat
scan so just make a mental note of that
because i'll come back to that later but
cholesterol is not a bad thing as long
as we have enough bile a couple points
about cholesterol
75 of cholesterol in our body is made by
our own body so because we need it
cholesterol is needed to make certain
hormones especially your sex hormones
like testosterone and even estrogen
cholesterol is needed to make cortisol
the main anti-inflammatory hormone in
your body cholesterol is needed for the
membranes of your cells
and without that you can't make the
membranes of your cell and cholesterol
is needed to make bile as well as
vitamin d
and without a gallbladder you can't
concentrate the bile so
if they remove the gallbladder
you're always going to be
somewhat deficient now it may not show
an obvious symptom
but think about all these other factors
that i talked about
a lack of vitamin a for example you
might not recognize or connect the dots
between
driving at night and not being able to
see at night and a bile deficiency it's
not necessarily a dietary vitamin a
deficiency you just can't extract that
vitamin a from your foods and what about
the conversion of the thyroid hormones
you may not connect the dots between a
lack of bile in a hypothyroid condition
all right so now let's kind of cover
some of the symptoms of a classic
gallbladder problem
and this can also cover a lack of bile
as well
all right number one bloating belching
burping feeling nauseous
right shoulder pain
pain or tightness in the right side of
your scapula or the right trap up here
which can then cause
tension in your muscles and literally
cause a spasm where it pulls out the
vertebra and pinches the nerve and
causes pain down the right side even
into the hand it can also go up into the
neck into your jaw cause right jaw pain
and even headaches on the right side of
your head and you'll be going to the
massage therapist for months and months
trying to work out this knot back here
when in fact it's coming from your
gallbladder because there's a nerve
right underneath your diaphragm right
next to the gallbladder called the
phrenic nerve that travels up to the
right side up into your neck right here
and so when you step in a dog's tail he
barks through his mouth right you
wouldn't want to mess with the mouth you
take the pressure off the tail you take
the pressure off the gallbladder by
making sure that you're not irritating
the gallbladder i will cover that at the
end
all right the next symptom would be
tightness underneath the right rib cage
okay because that's where the
gallbladder is located your gallbladder
kind of gets distended you might not
have a gallstone
but the bile ducts are in spasm or there
could be some sludge and it creates
either a tightness or a pain or an
irritation underneath the right rib cage
i had that problem as well as right
shoulder pain for about 12 years and i
had no clue on what it was and as a
result from that i've studied the
gallbladder and that's why i'm doing
this presentation right now all right
another symptom of a lack of bile
or a gallbladder problem would be
constipation
why because bile helps to lubricate the
colon okay
in fact if you actually take purify bile
salts in high quantities you can end up
with diarrhea so that's one indication
that tells you you're taking too much
bile all right another symptom i already
mentioned this is gallstones
and goal sludge which is just thickened
cholesterol without enough bile
also if you're not extracting
fat from your food
um you're going to crave fatty foods
that's another symptom
itching that's a symptom of a lack of
bile and high cholesterol especially if
you are on the ketogenic diet and you're
consuming a lot of fat and so the
solution
for gallbladder problems is not to go
extremely
low fat or lean protein is to have an
adequate amount of fat with the right
ratios with protein which i'll get to a
little bit later and it's to identify
what your problem is is your problem
maybe a fatty liver or you have
cirrhosis or you have some issue that
you can't make bile or are you on the
wrong eating plan i'll get to that very
soon all right here's some of the
problems um with surgery
that you will find out when you sign off
on the inform consent there's
complications it's not a little thing
it's not a completely safe
procedure
so you really need to understand what
you're getting into
before you get into it so here are some
risks number one injury to the bile
ducts
it happens in one out of 200 cases
where you might need another surgery and
there's a possibility of having
long-term damage to your liver all right
number two
bile leaks okay so now we have this this
leaky bile that's not being regulated
too well because you don't have a
gallbladder so there's nothing to
contract and release the bile not to
mention concentrate the bile but that
happens about seven percent of the time
and then they may have to use this
procedure it's called ercp
it's both in diagnosing and treating
stones in your bile ducts and the
problem with that it's pretty high risk
especially if you have asymptomatic
gallstones in these little ducts and a
duct is just a simple tube and the risk
of having more complications in fact
worse complications and symptoms than
you currently have is about 27
because the complications could be
pancreatitis
internal bleeding and in rare cases it
could be fatal all right next
complication is injury to your blood
vessels in your abdominal cavity
number four jaundice because there could
be of some obstruction created then you
have on this back up into the liver and
into the blood and then you start
looking yellow number five infection
despite
taking antibiotics
and using sterile equipment
all right number six you can get a
hernia right where you have the incision
number seven pancreatitis eight injury
to the bowel or liver all right number
nine blood clots number ten
a heart attack eleven
this occurs rarely but you could die
from the surgery and number twelve
continued symptoms that you originally
started with so one complication is this
procedure did not resolve the symptoms
all right so now that you know the
basics about the gallbladder you know
the basis about bile you know about the
symptoms you know about the
complications you know the function
let's talk about what you can do
whether you are trying to prevent going
into surgery with the gallbladder or you
already had
surgery and now you still have problems
or maybe you went through the surgery
and you don't have problems right now
these are some things that you need to
know about number one you want to get on
an eating plan that would have prevented
this problem in the first place okay and
so the main cause of the main problem
with the gallbladder which would be
gallstones would be a lack of bile but i
didn't necessarily discuss what causes a
lack of bile and i'm going to do that
right now
it could be
damaged from the liver it could be not
having a gallbladder it could be sludge
in the ducts that prevents the flow of
bile
it also could be high levels of insulin
in fact that's a very common cause of a
lack of bile your insulin is too high
because you have blood sugar issues
you're consuming a high carbohydrate
diet
another cause could be high levels of
estrogen
this is why women who are pregnant many
times end up with a gallbladder problem
or a gall stone or even
hypothyroid conditions at pregnancy
because when you have lack of bile you
can't convert the thyroid hormones so
too much estrogen can be a factor too
much cortisol from stress can cause a
lack of bile and being on a low-fat diet
whether you're a vegan or just go
low-fat could be a cause because we need
this saturated fat to trigger the
release of
bile
now also consuming
very very lean protein as in protein
powders
especially these protein powders that
are in a lot of these diets like ideal
protein
concentrated protein powder mixes and
consuming low-fat protein bars
especially with soy protein isolates can
be really hard on the gallbladder and in
practice i've had quite a few people
come in after doing these diets and i've
noticed a high incidence of gallbladder
problems after they started so you want
to avoid a low-fat diet you want to do
the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet with intermittent fasting so as to
not stress out the digestive system so
frequently the only thing i want to
mention about being on a high fat diet i
would do the ketogenic diet but i
wouldn't add additional fat like in
these keto cookies and these keto snacks
like a lot of people do
one special note about mct oil okay mct
oil is a type of fat that doesn't stress
the gallbladder out like other fats
so a little bit of mct oil might be okay
so number one get on a healthy keto
plan with intermittent fasting number
two supply
some purified bile salts to your diet
when you're eating so in other words
take some purified bile salts
with meals the one that i'm going to
recommend is called gall bladder formula
i put a link down below because in this
formula there's not just purify bio
salts but betaine hydrochloride to help
the stomach you need the stomach to be
very very acid to help release bile
salts and there's a lot of additional
factors to support the pancreas with
enzymes there's also herbs to help thin
the bile and i put a link down below for
more information on that all right
number three manual therapy now what i
mean manual therapy this is something
that i
initially experimented with in practice
and i developed a really
simple
um
but very effective technique that you
can do some gentle massage around the
gallbladder and the pancreas and the
digestive organs and i will put a link
down below of how to do this but
basically just helping the flow of this
sludge that could be backed up in your
bile ducts
so if you already had your gallbladder
removed and you probably have
some incision on the right side
you don't want to be massaging
um or doing any type of manual therapy
in that area why because there was an
injury to that area
instead you would want to work on the
opposite side on the pancreas side and i
put a diagram exactly where to press
it's basically the mirror image or
opposite point to where you had the
surgery so if you had surgery on the
right side about an inch inward off the
middle part of the midline
you start pressing or massaging very
gently on the opposite or left side
and you just press and feel around very
gently until you find a very very tender
spot and you just gently massage it for
a couple minutes and it will give you a
lot of relief if you have residual pain
so that's one thing but if you haven't
removed the gallbladder you can in
addition to massaging the left side you
can massage the right side too let's say
you did one through three and you still
have problems what do you do there's a
really great remedy you can do a search
on it on amazon it's called tudka okay
and tutcom is a type of bile salt
that is very very unique and it can help
thin
the bile so if you have sludge that is
backing up in these bile ducts and
creating a lot of discomfort
you can take tutcom on an empty stomach
you can take one to two at a time once
or twice a day depending on how severe
it is and give yourself a lot of relief
i would highly recommend you only take
this on an empty stomach because if you
take it with food it'll actually work on
the food
not necessarily kind of act as a drano
to help open up the clogged pipes so i
have a very interesting video in tucka
which i put a link down below but the
most important thing you need to do
right now
is get started with the eating plan a
healthy keto plan with intermittent
fasting i put three very simple videos
up on a playlist right here check it out
you